Planet Earth is so spectacular
it's easy to miss the smaller things in life.
Strawberry dart frogs are tiny little frogs
with a lot of personality.
And they're only about the size of my thumbnail.
We've brought this lens
that's really meant for scientific purposes.
And that allows us to get shots
that we wouldn't have been able to otherwise.
For days, we've been trying to get shots
of two males wrestling.
Because the males are territorial and quite competitive.
And all of a sudden, these two males lock
and they start going at it.
And it got to the point
where they actually jumped on the lens.
And as a wildlife filmmaker
you're always striving to film really natural behavior.
So that was just amazing.
I have quite a good amount of respect for goshawks.
Like it is really, really hard to fly through this forest.
They're not just trying to survive,
and trying just not to hit a tree, they're hunting.
Alright, let's go.
These goshawks fly fifty miles an hour through here.
Like, that must take
incredible amounts of energy and focus.
You don't just do that, easy.
I don't think there's any other way
to film the point of view of a goshawk.
You need something that's very agile, nimble.
Something that is forgiving.
That's why we have these ducts on this drone.
Because if you didn't have them,
you hit anything, the propeller breaks
and then the drone crashes.
This is the golden-tailed gecko.
Now I've been working with this gecko
for the last three years,
trying to film it in the wild.
We've been using this motion control rig
the way you'd use any other way of moving the camera,
except just on a really, really tiny and precise scale.
It's so close to these animals that are so small
that there's no way that we could do them by hand
and make them smooth and make them cinematic.
I think it's actually a really powerful storytelling tool
because you can be so specific with your shots.
And you can literally take the story
from one beat or one location, to the next.
-Can we replay that little bit?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yes!
-Yes!
See the world from a new perspective.
Tiny World.